luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome back
to the late hill pan show today we're talking how
to spot the next 100 x with a very good friend of
mine but before we jump in this is powered by icon
plus capital their vc firm and it is sponsored by
block five so block fire actually offering i think
the most competitive interest rates actually right
now around nine percent um maybe even nine and a
half percent on your stable coins so i've left
a link in the description and in the body of the
tweet so hit that you also get 250 when you sign
up so definitely check that out so we're going to
be talking about how to spot the next 100x with
a very good friend of mine so don't go anywhere
let's bring him in it is the ceo of old coinbase
shash gupta josh how are you i'm doing great how
are you leah i'm good i'm so excited to speak with
you um for those that don't know i feel like we
need to um explain the relationship here so shash
isn't just another person in crypto shash is the
person that really just made me stay in the crypto
space so i was working in crypto and then i left
in i think 2019 and then shash reached out to me
and he basically dragged me back in and i haven't
left since isn't that right yeah probably one of
the best things for this space as well right like
i always find it i always find it like something
i need to do is like not let people leave crypto
so that is something i find and something and
you were so talented before when you were doing
everything in terms of journalism and all uh so i
found it a little strange that you were planning
to leave so when i spoke with you i was like no
you cannot leave let's do something and uh yeah
having you in crypto is awesome now you've written
a book you've like what 250 million subscribers on
twitter something so so shash to me is like kind
of just like the godfather of crypto he knows
everything um he's taught me so much and so i
really just wanna yes don't shake your head so i
just wanna make sure we get all of that knowledge
out and um just get it out okay because this guy
knows unbelievable amounts of stuff basically just
a lot of stuff so before we no it's not pressure
it's not pressure no pressure knows good stuff so
we're gonna get out of him today and we're gonna
find out how to basically spot the best trends
understand how to navigate the crypto space
d5 nfts gaming everything because shash knows it i
promise you so let's do it before we go into this
tell us about your background oh well for me
like i i used to practice law in india and then
i was like i want to understand more towards the
business side of things so i moved to singapore
started like working with the company and
then started a little startup back in 2014
wasn't the best of ideas then try to find a
new industry which was interesting you know
and had sort of money in it and was like a new
industry um so i looked at 3d printing ar vr
ai you know all that jazz and then my sort of
ears and eyes fell upon cryptocurrency in 2016
i was like this is fascinating but not coming from
a finance or technology background i kind of knew
that you know it's crypto which is tech and then
you know currency which is like finance and i knew
i kind of had to work twice as hard as anybody
else to even understand what was going on so
from 2016 to 2017 i was literally like a
anthropologist in the space just trying to
understand you know how people think about
the space what is being built where is the
future of the industry you know what what what's
really happening here and that probably was the
best thing i did in terms of you know getting
aware of everything from a macro perspective
and then in 2017 when i decided to really
you know start figuring out how to survive
of it because i was living off my wife at that
point of time um i was you know i was like okay
let's figure out what to do and i thought i could
do investing but i really didn't have any finances
at that point of time i could do trading but
trading sound like seemed like something which is
too much work for very little result
like it's not something which is for me
uh then you could work for an organization but
after spending a year in the space i did realize
that you don't want a macro perspective like you
want a macro perspective you don't want to sort of
be a bit tunnel vision and organizations
themselves were you know people who were trying
to experiment with stuff funding was easy because
it's like a fringe space so you can get money from
crazy people for doing crazy things and that's
what's happening right now even till date but uh
that was another thing so what i decided is like
okay like i spoke to a bunch of friends like i
spoke to a friend and we started this youtube
channel together called coin buzz just like a
simple way to uh you know tell people what's
happening in the space as we understood it
uh and then i've been running that since 2017
uh we've we have about we just crossed 300 000
subscribers on the channel which is like a
super cool thing i don't know why so many
people are watching that but i i love what i do
it's been amazing the journey has been excellent
i've learned so much i've met so many amazing
people uh money has been decent especially this
year it's been pretty uh awesome to tell
you the truth so uh all in all like that's
like a pretty extended brief on who i am yeah
well major congrats on passing that um youtube
milestone so that's for guys if you missed it
that's altcoin buzz so check their youtube out
um they always spot the top trends and i need to
tell a story so shash told me over a year ago to
get into several different coins and i didn't um
i don't know why um i just didn't and obviously um
i don't know what i can't even think of come on
name it okay god name it i told you to get like
into engine at like four cents which is like three
dollars 60 cents right now i told you to get into
you know quan network at less than five dollars
like four and a half dollars that's like 288 i
think it was actually three and a half i think it
was like three and a half dollars at the time yeah
and then i told you again to rent protocol which
was like under 10 cents i totally get into chain
link and only get into uh one wait we need to talk
about one question yes harmony you told me to get
into harmony um it was it was like dirt cheap i
had literally 15 pounds in like a spare wallet so
i was like i'll throw it into one okay it is now
worth 700 pounds why didn't i put more in shash
i don't know i i don't know that's on you
but here's the thing right what what here's
the thing right like it it takes a while it
really takes a while to start seeing this and
and it's fine like i've been like you i've been
totally opposite of you and both are complicated
like if you don't take the risk you're in trouble
if you take too much risk you're in trouble right
like like for example we will get into the mean
coin side of things and what i really feel about
it as well yeah but uh like the best thing is to
sort of manage your risks pretty carefully but
that said like the other coins that i did tell you
to sort of get into like chili's i was so bullish
when it was like well under a cent the things
gone to like it went to like 88 cents like that
was just insane and yeah it sort of paid off sort
of throughout the bear market like from 2016 17 18
19 and 20 and then march 2020 was like horrendous
time like the entire market crashed the because of
the whole stock market and oil market crashing and
it was really bad and i think around that time is
when i decided to double down on my efforts with
altcoin buzz as well and i was like okay it's now
whenever i go all in and like give it my best shot
and probably the best decision asked you to join
the team as well i asked everybody in the team to
sort of uh you know get their act together because
i could sense it where everybody was sensing
doom i kind of felt that that's going to be
the bottom uh of course it was really scary
right uh it was tough also because at that
point of time to sort of run altcoin buzz
it was we barely had any revenue at that
point of time so what i had done is a little bit
bitcoin that we've saved and actually instead of
selling it because i was so bullish on bitcoin
i had taken a loan on bitcoin had taken a left
nice all my bitcoin got liquidated right like
that was the worst moment ever like i lost oh no
yeah it was pretty bad who did you go through wait
oh my god wait what what what i had no idea yeah
it happened it was pretty bad like i was pretty
shaken up for a bit and then kind of got my head
together and i was like well let's let's start
all over again and then i started all over again
yeah it was tough but worth it yeah totally
worth it because your all your calls have been
essentially from what i know spot on um but i want
to understand how you spot these calls basically
i remember you explaining quant to me um a while
ago and you were like yeah it's like the middle
chain and then at the time i was just like yeah
i have no idea what you're saying but i was like
trying to keep up but now tell me how do you spot
the these trends like how did you spot harmony
all right so at that point of time when i got
into harmony was at a time when ethereum 2 was
being conceptualized and guys that harmony
had already done the whole sharding bit and
created sort of what ethereum 2.0 was gonna
be and it was pretty clear to see that the way
even in a down market where a few people were
using d5 ethereum was having a bit of a hard time
to survive now people love the decentralization
of ethereum but if you can have something which is
less decentralized now but works but the fees is
much much cheaper you'll be able to have much more
movement on it and that's why sort of looking at
layer ones that were more efficient and layer twos
uh like you know matic etc that are gonna
make things better made complete sense and
uh because it was going to do well and here's
the thing right like my belief in it was so
so much that kind of knew that everything around
it and everything that was trying to kind of
compete with it improvise on it is going to do
really well so i was actually pretty bullish
on cosmos as well uh cosmos didn't perform as
well as i thought because evms which is ethereum
virtual machines they took over the entire
space in terms of you know the development so
like bsc came out with its evm and binance chain
was actually based on cosmos tendermint sdk
right but they realized that it's very hard to
survive on the decks that they had made which is
called finance decks and that was called chain
at that point of time they instantly kind of
went to binance marching which is a different
chain all together and that's when i realized
that the evms and those ethereum based ones will
start performing better so it was easy to see why
something like a matic a harmony a bsc etc will
start performing fairly well simultaneously
you know when these started doing well other
chains that had somebody backing them like for
example uh bsc is backed by binance uh then there
is solana which is sort of backed by ftx right and
ftx is another beast out there right so if they're
gonna support a chain it's gonna do really well so
it was pretty easy to see from that perspective
but but the the question you're asking like how
do you identify from starting up right and one
of the best ways is figure out what you use in
the first place so the first thing is things that
work so there are two types of investments current
projects and then future speculations right
so when you look at current projects it's like
i have already built something so if you
are going to use it and you like using it
then simply because you know you should consider
yourself as an average user at that point
yeah at that point when you're testing it
out and then when you when you kind of play
with it and you like it for example that's
what happened with me by nance in 2017 right
i ended up buying binance coin for 40 cents simply
because it was uh something i wanted to use they
had about 200 000 users i remember it was october
of 2017 and it was just launched like a few
months back it was gaining traction and they were
listing all the hot coins at that point of time
that i wanted to trade buy etc so i just got into
finance and i love the idea that you could get 75
discount on fees at that point of time you
could get 75 discount i was like that's
amazing so i bought some bnb and i realized i
used to pay initially like sometimes between
five to eight bnb for a trade right like
it was just crazy because it was so cheap
and uh then like that became like a fairly decent
investment for me and i didn't even want to look
at bnb as an investment and eventually realized
you know okay wow if you use something using
something then others are going to use it there
will be far more speculation on it sort of that
kind of got me into understanding the use cases
for stuff like chain link so interesting use cases
for projects that are having a growing user
base it's an easy buy for example uni swap
is one of the easiest buys out there like when
uni swap token was launched i was like you can go
all and you will never sort of you know get into
any issues because uni swap is d5 like 95 percent
of d5 is pretty much uni swap right now pancake
swap is uni swap sushi office uni swap quick swap
is uni swap all other am n's are pretty much
uni swap in my opinion so and you'll swap v3 is
literally a game changer people haven't realized
how amazing the tech behind v3 is like v3 is
far superior than v2 it's just so many things need
to be built on it v3 is essentially like ethereum
for trading and amm it just needs a lot more
tools to be built on it to really change
the skill the scope of things however the big
challenge that uni swap is facing is that this
stuck to ethereum and had uni swap sort of looked
at it from a broader perspective and started
launching cross-chain solutions with matic with uh
bsc with solana etc etc yeah then uni swap would
be the king out there like literally there would
have been the entire d5 space can it do that can
it can it do that can it innovate so multi-chain
multi-chain is something that can be done that
means you can have your product run on many chains
cross chains means that you can cross liquidity
from one chain to the other which may not be
mandatory in the beginning but eventually there
will be tools that will exist that will allow for
cross chain uh as well so having multi-chain and
being like okay we are also building on solana
we're building on avalanche we're building on
tezos we're building on hashgraph we're building
on bsc whatever right is would have been fabulous
for uni swap they would have been unstoppable in
my opinion and i think that's where sort of by
bitcoin maximalism or eth maximalism or any chain
maximalism sort of kind of narrows the focus of
even project builders that should be able to sort
of try and see you know how they could attempt
to do stuff what i'm trying to say here is that
what what they did is not essentially wrong but
it was their choice that kind of allowed other
projects to do a lot more right like that's
that's what gave birth to stuff like sushi swap or
pancake swap or quick swap etc and like hundreds
of these swaps which are essentially uni swap in
its nature so anyways the point i was saying was
that if you use stuff and you like using it
you should have their coins because they're
going to do well if you use die and you've taken
the loan on maker then maker is one of the best
coins to buy as well if you're using a launch pad
whether it's truss swap or ignition or damage or
an engine starter start buying like those tokens
because if they're going to launch good projects
and you believe in the industry and you believe
in the capacity that's one way of looking at it
the other way is more speculatory right where
nothing is being built but we are speculating on
things which will happen into the future right
so at that point of time we start looking at
the founders themselves have they had experience
in the past in successful projects what have they
built do they understand product building do they
understand marketing do they understand community
building do they understand communications do they
understand regulations compliance all these things
right so basically three main heads come into
force one is product and technology second one
is regulation and compliance and the third one is
marketing communications pr and community building
right if if you believe that the founders would
be able to do that then at that point when you're
investing in a product which is not launched you
simply invest in in the fact that the founders
will be able to accomplish this so that time
you're essentially investing in the abilities of
the founders so this is sort of like a very simple
breakdown in my opinion uh yeah if i could go on
on it but i'll stop here no it's really useful
and really helpful um it's really interesting
what you said about um something that you actually
use so um because of you i use the crypto com card
and we were talking about this before we went
live because um crow that their token or their
coin is now up i think 31 percent um in 24 hours
which is wild um so it's the same thing like i
i've actually decided to leave my money and crow
because i'm like hey i'm using this thing you know
i'm enjoying the experience they have amazing
partnerships ufc um formula one aston martin
and all these um other amazing sporting events so
yeah you're totally right um but i'd love to get
your thoughts on solana because i just can't wrap
my head around it and some people say you know
it's the ethereum killer some people say well all
coexist um but they switched the network on and
off um the other day and that's kind of concerning
so that doesn't really scream decentralization to
me and like you said you know it's backed by ftx
so talk me through solana where do you stand on it
so here is where the difference between
becoming from a user to an investor
kind of comes into play right now i use a
lot of products right and if i see a product
which has problems which are fixable but they're
good at some things right for example if if there
is a tech issue it's not like it cannot be fixed
right neck tech issues can always be fixed but
if they just don't understand communication
they don't understand regulation compliance
setting up the right infrastructure building a
community then i have bigger concerns at that
moment the point i'm trying to make here is
that the the problem that solana has in terms
of tech decentralization etc you can't look
at it as an investment now you need to see it
can these problems be fixed five years from
now um here's the thing right we're not in the
business of gambling if you're gambling then this
conversation becomes redundant if you want to get
today and come out tomorrow then it's as good
as getting into a meme coin right and kind of
yeah that's how bimco investing works but what
we're looking is hey am i safe with my money in
this project and will i make many falls keeping
in it in the next five years can they fix these
technological issues or whatever issues right so
every every project has many issues the bigger it
gets the bigger the issues become the more visible
the more transparent these issues become so the
question always comes is do you believe that they
can fix it and as an investor your job is not to
speculate on the present we are investing in the
future right we are all futurist that's the way we
should be working in general right and because
that is the case if you use something now you
work it works fine here's the thing you think
using ethereum is a good experience right now
it's not you think all these nfts we've been
buying it's like you've minting faces like
hundreds and hundreds of dollars right now it's
incredibly crazy but is that not bullish is that
not a problem that can be fixed imagine leah if
everything was fine and bitcoin transactions were
free it was completely decentralized even more
than what it is now there is the opportunities
for people like you and me the reason there is
an opportunity for you and me is because things
are messed up you realize that no but now i do
if it was a hunky-dory for everyone where would
we make the money from because they are not and
because we see it from a future perspective is
why we will succeed and that's why keeping
a long-term macro vision is the best way to
survive in the crypto space because every time
i see a problem and i see people running away
is when i get to work and i realize and analyze
can this problem be fixed are the founders smart
enough to work on it and fix it if the answer is
yes take all my money it's as simple as that and
i've done it so many times with with like so much
success that i can kind of count on this formula
it's a very interesting perspective and it's
um it's totally right actually because when
you i always say this the fact that we are
so early means there's so much opportunity
um and if everything was sorted then how can
we innovate and how can we make money um it's
true but in in terms of things like um polka
dot then you know people are so bullish on it
um and i understand the whole para chains um i
understand the whole you know like the octopus
with all the all the different chains and you
know they can they're all interoperable and so
there's less congestion and you know you can't
just like set up anything like you can do on um
ethereum you know anyone could just create a meme
coin um as an erc20 token polkadot requires um
the auctions and everything going on um but
you see i i find it difficult to understand
i understand what it does but i find it
difficult to understand how it's different
from you know solana or something like that
um and you know and whether or not i should
be bullish on it i find that really hard
to really distinguish those differences
sure like i don't know what's the best analogy
to give here like i could kind of think of
something like you know you have mcdonald's
and then you have gordon ramsay and then
both of them can do fairly well right uh but
that said just taking polka dot for an example
so there will be meme coins that will be possible
on polka dot it's just that the meme coins won't
be running on a parachute so what they've done
is now they they have gotten people to support
the creme de la creme projects by having a
crowd loan system which could in my opinion
cost somewhere between 50 million dollars to 500
million dollars in terms of crowd support and dot
and then these projects will in turn uh the
people who support these projects will in turn get
you know uh tokens given to them right so one of
the ones i am most bullish on is called affinity
uh it's a project by the engine guys uh i've
always been such a big fan of engine that was
pretty much here's the thing i first mentioned
my first nft back in april april of 2018
and i knew exactly nft is going to be one of the
hottest things out there and i was giving it free
to our community and people like i don't want your
stupid nfts like what is this energy [ __ ] right
but it it is what it is um the experience was
extremely good for me to at least understand how
you know you can have these interesting tokens
that can be you know made into art music etc etc
so coming back to polka dots so infinity is one of
those chains which i think is going to be pretty
cool if you stake your dot on it and here's the
thing now the question is don't don't don't look
at it from whether ethereum will be killed by
polkadot or solana whatever it doesn't matter
what matters is will ethereum do well with solana
do well will polka dot do well and which one do
you think will do well the most right so because
there is no animosity between the two because as
as an investor you can hold all three so why
would you bother about like here's the thing
people think ethereum is gonna you know beat
bitcoin what the hell kind of a statement is that
like you have bitcoin and you have ethereum and
you have solana so it's like you you're kind of
invested in the whole industry in general so
and it'll be fun to see like here's the thing
if you're invested in all maybe you know your
one child does better than the other child but
at the end of the day we're going nowhere we're
here to stay so coming back to polkadot side
of things and this is where you know polkadot
sort of in my opinion has shown pure genius is
every top project which is trying to build on
polka dot is getting their entire community to
not stake their coin they have gotten them to stay
polka dot yeah yeah yeah which is ingenious like
which is just really why would they do that
when they want them to stake their own coin
now because only when you stick dot you can get
a para chain it's just sheer genius oh i see
and because that sort of polka dot may not perform
badly even in the worst of the bear market because
if their parachains do well and people start
using them the dot market is going to go
kaboom like it's going to do really really well
simply because right now it's it's like i feel
i mean actually i had a very crazy bullish
statement regarding polka dot but i'm not
going to say it on yours no tell us tell
us what's it about can you give us a clue
no no it's something weird right like it's
something stupid very stupid to say but i i kind
of felt that if any coin like the way the dynamics
of it were built could beat bitcoin it could be
polkadot and if it works out right if the parrot
chain system just works fine people start using it
because you're not comparing apple you're not
even comparing apples to oranges right like
bitcoin is digital gold but at the current moment
what ethereum and you know ethereum competitors or
friends whatever you want to call them have become
is more akin to so if bitcoin is like digital gold
then these guys are like amazon or google's of the
web 3 error right yes and you don't say that hey
google is going to beat gold right you don't
care like that's not the silly thing to say
but sort of bitcoins legacy is unbeatable
that's never going to change like bitcoin
is always going to be a king but uh in terms of
really what polka dot is capable of doing and if
they launch a bunch of good para chains it can do
fantastically well and i'm not i'm not like it's
not really my biggest investment or anything
however analyzing it is something that i felt
the the amount of power it can get and this will
depend on parachain launches if they launch well
and people start using them and they start getting
traction then i will be mega bullish on it right
right now there are bit of ifs so that's why it
is a percentage because i'm buying on speculation
but eventually when it becomes more reality i'd be
happy to invest more in it okay so just going back
a sec you mentioned that ages ago well not ages
ago a few years a few years is like it's like
10 years in crypto um you were giving out nfts
um and you're really good at spotting um those
trends you were going crazy um about d5 before the
d5 summer blew up i remember you were telling me
about compound and rv um and i was just like ah
what is that um so um how do you how do you know
what's next um you know nfts are the current thing
um and i do think that that will continue i see a
lot of value there even d5 i think they'll
continue but how do you know what's next
well it starts with the basic infrastructure
level right so what what can be done once it
becomes a reality the thing is d5 literally
started with make a dao the moment you could
lock in your ethereum on a smart contract and
take a loan on it in a stable coin called die
right that was the inception of decentralized
finance that that actually started it and
when did that start when was that launched i think
maker dow started in 2018 if not before i think
18 yeah 18. uh and ave was called etheland in
fact i was a part of a demo when ethel and did
its demo in 2017 and i was like this this stuff
is weird man this is not going to work and then
after following see here's the thing right in
terms of time i felt i felt like the d5 movement
had happened quite a bit by the time i got bullish
on it as well no way you are still waiting you're
still selling it was it was the perfect time
to get into d5 and it was i'm glad i got into
that time but uh in terms of trends i'd by finding
them early still very early in a lot of trends and
and the nft subculture is nothing like the crypto
subculture like nft the ballgame is a different
animal altogether you cannot i have to spend way
more time in understanding and analyzing nfts
because it's nothing like the crypto space it the
the way the people are investing in it the people
are thinking in it the whole mentality behind it
it's a separate subculture then crypto absolutely
different so the point i'm trying to make here
is that i have so many interesting questions that
i'm still trying to answer and maybe for some
people it's just easy answers but stuff like
the entire nft action is on ethereum literally all
of it barely anything on solana though solana is
the second hottest barely anything on matic even
though matic is easily accessible through open c
open c is the hottest nft why why given it would
be cheap it's obviously cheaper right to do that
because it doesn't matter because
an nfp is valuable the more fees you
pay on it i guess i'm just saying i'm
talking out of my butt right now but
the point is that i i'm still trying to figure out
this question why is there no nfd action on bsc
and i i'm bullish on a lot of interesting nft
projects on and by nfp i mean art nfds not game
nfts game nfts is a different animal altogether
we'll get to that later on but the art nft side
is just and it is such a fascinating subculture
the kind of things that are being built on it
like i got extremely i studied about 180 nft art
projects last one month uh and uh the one that
i loved the most was this one called eponym
and it's 3d art right like it's how it works is
when you could mint it when their generation one
was launched you give it a word or phrase and in
within a minute it will design an artwork for you
and if you spend time looking at the art and
the words you've given you can't believe it's
made by an ai like it literally blew my mind
wait wait wait so you're saying i i would just
use this platform put in some words so say you
know i want to make like a political piece or
something i'd write like freedom sovereignty you
know personal responsibility and then it would
just create some kind of masterpiece yes i need
to try this yes no you can't do it because there
is no time when you can mint it so it's smart like
so what what they did is for their generation one
they had 10 000 pieces that people had to put in
a word or a phrase or whatever to be able to mint
these nfts right and the artwork is really
fascinating it's really fascinating like i
spent some of them are just garbage because they
just didn't turn out right whatever in terms of
design they weren't aesthetically pleasing to
me i wouldn't call them garbage they just won
but that said some of the ones that really
appealed to me and they told the story of the
phrase written it blew my mind as to how this
is possible and now they're doing something
called a generation two right and the beauty
is generation two you can write more parameters
what kind of a texture do you want what kind of
a background do you want what colors do you want
there are a lot of things that you can
specify in gen 2 but hear this to make
one gen 2 you have to burn two gen ones like
you literally have two of generation one
nfts to make a gen 2 now this is so
smart because the supply of gen 1 reduces
but then there are three smart contracts that
are taking place one gen one being burnt second
gen one being burnt and the third gen two being
minted and the piece is three times now so not
only do you have to mint a gen two by burning two
gen ones which are already half an eighth each
like two gens right that's like four and
a half thousand dollars plus minting fees
on top for three smart contracts it's going to be
so expensive that if they turn out nice they will
be one of the hottest most expensive projects in
the market what's the project called again eponym
yeah eponine e-p-o-n-y-m hey i just have a few of
them i bought them very expensive of the market
i don't know those guys like i'm not marketing
them or whatever but i'm just fascinated
by it that is fascinating that is crazy i
need to check that out where do you see um
where do you see the whole nft space going um and
also and also the metaverse yeah are you bullish
on the metabolism i think i think the nft side
right now there is a bit of a bear market with the
pfp sort of nfts which is profile picture nfts in
in a way oh okay so how do you find out that there
is a bear market like not really a bear market
there's a the floor prices have gone down a bit
i understand because i think is going up so the
prices of because people are like wow man eat is
going to go nuts so people have started taking
profits a bit of their nfps so the nft market
the profile picture one's gone down a bit but
there are three types of basic nft markets of
the ones that i have analyzed one is these profile
picture nfts stuff like kong's uh punks etc and
then you have these art nfds which i find super
fascinating there are so many collections that
are worth spending some time checking out on and
then you can also create fabulous things like
there is this tool in which you can design your
own gallery and it's a full like an individual
metaverse sort of a gallery that means yeah it's
a free space where all your friends can check
out your artwork and stuff that you own uh it's
called uh it sounds like uh it sounds like terror
i don't um it sounds like terra virtua yeah yeah
yeah it's called on on cyber so terra virtua is
building its own sort of a collector's den right
in which you can have it in a hangar like in a
airline hangar you can keep your artwork and your
you know their collectibles and all the ieps that
they have terra virtual is fascinating but but
stuff like that is available on the east side
uh i did not know so i'm pretty fascinated by it
uh but yeah the nft and the third type of nfts is
gaming blockchain yeah so gaming nfts are are
super cool because it's like an nft with a design
but with the use case so there is rarity in it
but there is use case in it as well and the future
of these nfps is that they are going
to get more and more dynamic in nature
so wait just i just want to jump in so when when
people like gaming nfts are you literally talking
about like swords guns um or okay and are you
also talking about like um maybe characters or
is it more just like weapons and things like
that no it could be a blueprint of a level
oh no way it can be anything and and the beauty
of it is that it's dynamic the future nfps will
be very dynamic that means leia if you if
you played a game and you had a sword in it
yes there is a chance that your sword could have
dynamic character to it that means it starts
deteriorating every time you play with it so the
color of it will change and it will become old as
well and it's an nft at the same time that means
the rarity of it the the online the the blockchain
nature remains the same but the quality of it has
increased reduced aged etc etc so a lot of these
fascinating dynamic things are being put into
nfts but here's the thing on each every time you
add a dynamic element and you want to save it on
the blockchain there is a fees element to it and
that's why stuff like infinity becomes extremely
bullish is because they're building the entire
thing and in fact they're working closely with
dr gavin wood himself the founder of polkadot
to build the standardization of uh the nft on
polkadot and it's going to be really one of the
coolest things which is what does that mean though
the standardization of nfts what does that mean
so what we have in terms of standardization on
ethereum is two basic standards which which are
most popular and nfts one is called erc720 called
erc1155 and uh there is like a bit of uh coding
difference between the two like you have erc20 for
fungible tokens right basically things with you
know yeah yeah limited supply which is one equal
to one but for nfts these two are very popular
standards but because on parity things can be much
more complicatedly programmed it's going to be
far more dynamic and the kind of things you
can build with nfts on the polka dot chain
will be extremely extremely dynamic and
very very cool stuff is going to happen
uh for the gaming side specifically so uh what
was your question again but yeah anyways so
i'm getting excited about it yeah yeah yeah
so um just for those who are tuning in um
at the beginning of the show we were talking
about how shash gave me all these different um
tips for um tokens and coins to buy um over a year
ago they've now gone to astronomical prices and
obviously i didn't buy them um but i have bought
um e5 because shash told me to and i put quite
a bit of money into it so i was like whatever it
doesn't matter either i win or i lose but i should
do it so i've done it so i am now inherently
bullish on nft gaming stuff so i'm excited for
that um let's talk about memes um are you in any
meme coins did you get the bottom of sheeb or doge
the first rule of meme coin for anyone is do not
talk about meme coins that's the first rule and
simply because it's pure gambling right and we
we love to gamble and and by saying that it's
pure gambling it is pure gambling so the point
i'm trying to make here is that if you want to
buy a meme coin like especially when it comes
to like even on my old coinbus chat on telegram
right i'm pretty active then we're talking to the
community on a daily basis a lot right the only
time i get a little old is when people are talking
about these random meme coins and the reason is
it's fine you can buy them you can make money
off them if you're smart you should be doing that
the only thing is don't get your followers and
people to buy them or get into them because
they will definitely go to zero very very fast
like it's not zero maybe maybe they will crash
oh crash yeah so so the point is that do you wanna
buy a meme coin is going to a casino and putting
you know all your money on black or white whatever
right like it's just going and saying here is my
money you might win see here's the thing there is
a lot of ways to win uh but it's just so much like
gambling that at least i have not been able to
break it down into science and if i can't at least
feel like i'm doing something intelligent i cannot
get myself to sort of you know feel proud about it
even if it makes the money yeah that's my answer
to that no i think it's great um so we've got
a lot of people tuning in right now everybody is
really enjoying um your knowledge they're finding
it really valuable um so i figured that um it
might be nice just to give us maybe the top i
don't know five coins um obviously altcoins that
you're bullish on right now um sorry to put you
on the spot but everybody's really enjoying um
listening to you and hearing and what you have
to say so yeah what are like the top five projects
that you're bullish on obviously you can repeat
the ones that you've mentioned yeah of course like
everything i'm gonna say i i will hold and i will
have like a bag of it for sure i was extremely
bullish on i mean still am on cro uh when uh
you know when they announced their main net coming
and i've always been bullish on it so that's
one of the points i really really like i've
always been a fan of affinity and engine since
2018 in fact i've been in crypto.com which
is called monaco uh since 2017 i've been in
finance since 2017 i've been an engine since 2018
um so these are some of those projects that i've
always been in and i've been in fact even buying
more and stuff and like it's been a good journey
holding on to them um what else am i bullish on so
many there are so many amazing projects that are
happening i'm a huge fan of uniswap uh engine just
launched their launchpad called engine starter
uh which is run by a team i'm i work very closely
with them as well um there are tons of games that
are launching on engine starters so that's a
project that i'm super excited about and then
that said right like the point is find projects
that people intend to use if you use launch pads
buy launch by tokens and if your launchpad has
problems if it cannot be fixed right i'd say
the same thing again if these problems cannot be
fixed get out like sell it and get out like it
takes nothing to sell a token and getting out of
it the problem is the investors spend so much time
holding coins with projects that they have stopped
believing in but it takes a minute or maybe half a
day to sell whatever you stop believing in
and go to something that you do will even
uh i'm i'm a big fan of polka dot so i think
that's super cool i love ethereum for sure
i love many other projects that are building on
solana that's a cool ecosystem silica is doing
some fabulous stuff i'm a big kind of chili's
like my portfolio might have over 200 projects
so i can name them all and i i love them all
like my kid you know what about avalanche
what about avalanche people are like
shouting about avalanche right now
i have yet to test too many things on it it it's
really cool but there's only so much i have in
terms of capacity to test but we put out like in
terms of content that we put out on our coin bus
there's a huge research team it's not
just me or my ideas or my bags that matter
it's not the case we cover a variety of things
and avalanche is one of those projects harmony
is another project we cover very very often very
regularly and if people are using so here's the
thing right if people are using it and the number
of users is going up then it's it's already
looking like a good investment because user base
is equal to speculator speculation based right
where are you seeing these comments though like i
have nothing oh you're not seeing the comments um
they're loving it everyone is loving it
i'm reading everything as you're speaking
um i'll put some of them up on the screen um pn
says what about matic um doug phantom andrew jones
avex is fast and cheap af jamie says he's british
on my channel which is great everyone loves you um
that's nice look harry harry miller
really enjoys your your um your insight
great interview yeah i saw the comments i was
like sitting on this private chat thing which
was totally empty and i was like where are you
here like russell he is smart shush is smart
yeah thank god somebody somebody saw through
it no you are um i want to just like yeah
no god what were you going to say no no go what
are you going to say now people just think that
i'm good looking and i'm not smart so i don't
want them to be it's both it's both come on um so
let's swerve a little bit um because one thing as
well which you taught me in this space um was to
have a macro perspective not just um necessarily
about um investing but in times of business and
how to deal with people um and how to kind
of just like manage yourself and your brand
um and uh you always you can't remember
what you said to me you said something like
what did you say like dogs bark but you said
something to me and i can't remember and just
like not rising to rubbish online and and just
you know create building good relationships so
altcoin buzz i know that you right now you don't
take sponsorships or things like that you only
talk about coins which you're actually invested
in um and you're all about um all you like right
so but you're all about like the ethics
of things so talk about the importance of
um ethics and therefore you know slowly
building and having longevity in this space
so here's the thing right like the true
power in crypto really is in the community
the projects that realize that uh wow
i'm getting good comments that's amazing
thanks guys uh yeah i'm kind bless you now
sorry to distract you i'm just putting them up
shash is a wise man yes sorry go on so let's
talk about longevity and ethics yeah so at the
end of the day really like every time i feel
like i am getting bogged down by a short-term
mindset and i'm getting scared and you will
have those moments where you're feeling like
everything's going to go bad things are
looking problematic there seems like trouble
really looking into from a long-term perspective
listen to some of andreas antonopoulos's videos
really like you know it becomes extremely easy to
kind of calm down go into a bit of a zen mode and
then look at it from a long-term perspective i
have i have really struggled through the crypto
space over the last four years so many times but
every time i've only come back stronger that means
that there is a cost of education that you have
to pay to survive in this space the the market
is extremely bullish right now it is going
to have a correction right weak hands will
get out people will feel like oh my god like i
was so excited then and then eventually they will
feel like you know oh you know what did i do this
means makes no sense and all that fomo that they
have will instantly be created into fudd the way
to not create your fomo into fudd is only one way
to have knowledge to understand what you're
buying to understand why you're buying it
if you intend to buy bnb and you intend to use
it and the price goes down you can still be fine
because you still intend to use binance exchange
right but if you buy a meme coin that you bought
because 20 youtubers were talking about it and
people were you know kind of shouting about
these meme coins and then suddenly they go down
i have seen so many companies people influencers
leave the space so many times right that the best
way to have a business is think about how you
build a community no matter how hard the things
is it's very hard for us and i've realized this
it's not actually hard but it becomes hard after
a while when you suffered so much by putting out
we started with very random content right like in
2017 when we started the channel we didn't expect
to grow it that big the goal was just to have some
fun right like if you're bullish on something as
you learned you talk about it and eventually we
sort of matured we got better analysts we got rid
of like people who would just make random content
but actual people who would analyze stuff we would
get into the depths of things we will look into
some really smart ways as to where the trends
are headed and now everything that we're doing
is very well thought out and calculated in fact
our videos have finally started performing
performing much better is because people are
able to see that you know some of the some of the
information which is out there they they say abc
is also good and abc is also bad right like they
say it in both ways and then amplify whichever
ways it goes so we we try to just focus on stuff
that we're buying when we find getting exciting
for example we started an nft segment on the
website i'm not invested in any nft per se except
epo name the one i just spoke to you about
right and that also i started buying after
two months of research the thing is that i buy
things after months of research right people buy
after two hours or two minutes of watching a
youtube video there is a bit of a difference
right there right and and if you're going
to buy something in two minutes you will
have fear of it in two minutes also and that's why
bitcoin holders are far better at holding bitcoin
than altcoin guys and that's why bitcoin has more
stability than altcoins for a few reasons one
bitcoin has more regulation altcoins have
less regulation right uh bitcoin has far
more distributed as a system all coins are not
that distributed right now and nor are they that
decentralized so there are these basic differences
between bitcoin and odd coin but all altcoin takes
inspiration from bitcoin itself if you look at
vanity that pumps old coins and by vanity i mean
stuff like you know what pumps an altcoin staking
we're getting staking we're burning tokens uh we
are launching liquidity mining we are launching
this we're doing a partnership with some random
project all these things lead to a pump right it
all takes inspirations from bitcoins event like
halving right even like halving is for like once
in a four years it takes place which makes bitcoin
extremely bullish and that event is what gives
inspiration to all coins to start doing stuff as
well i've completely gone off course to whatever
question you were asking me unfortunately no it's
fine no it's fine i think it was great um you know
you went into openings and what pumps oakland i
think that's great i was i actually started asking
you just about like ethics and longevity and um
you know staying honest to your audience um and
only taking on you know only sort of working with
projects um where you actually see value um but
but i i feel like i feel like we covered it um
you're writing a book am i allowed to say that
yeah yeah i'm working on it i said it all right
let's hear it so shash is writing a book can you
tell us about it so i'm trying to figure out more
from an economics perspective of how how altcoins
work and trying to talk more about the altcoin
perspective how you can invest in them how to
look at it from a short term long term perspective
uh how how to even see it from so here's
the thing right we're all futurists
how to become a futurist is is what i think
everybody should be wanting to do right you put
this stuff right it blushes me and then i can't
think anymore like nobody gives me compliments
like this man guys this is a shash is pure gold
we need more of those words yeah sorry guys i need
this stuff and my brain stops working because it's
too much compliment i just thought i was all about
good looks but nobody cared about my brains when
i come to your chat and now it seems like i have
brains as well so amazing sorry sorry sorry so
go on we're all futurists tell us about your book
yeah so i've been writing it for a while now and
i want to kind of like just put out my thoughts
and make it easy for people to sort of have a
long-term understanding of the space one of one of
the biggest problems in this space is that every
every group of people they try to make it very
they try to build sometimes animosity amongst
each other but there is no animosity right like
people who own bitcoin can own ethereum can own
everything so there is no like oh silica is better
than elrond or you know like corn network is
better than ripple and this and that there is no
ripple versus bitcoin in fact each coin sort of
complements the rest so in my book i'm trying to
kind of talk about how you can cut through that
[ __ ] and focus on how you should be looking at
the space grow yourself as an individual and
grow your portfolio smartly i'm still here
my camera just switches off after 30 minutes hang
on there we go i'm here wow yeah it's annoying
so how you can grow your portfolio how you
can navigate the space what else can we expect
uh that's it the rest you'll
have to read the book right like
when's it so so what's the name of the book and
when's it coming out uh i i'm not telling you
anything right now that's everything is gonna
come out in due time okay it's really exciting
like it's not it's not that exciting my book is
not going to do anywhere close to uh most of the
books it's just something i'm doing because it's a
bucket list thing for me it won't be that exciting
trust me i'm going to get it i'm excited so where
can people follow you everybody's been asking for
your twitter um how can people follow you and
how can they follow upcom buzz it's nothing to
do with porn but my twitter is called shash
xxx right yeah why i have no idea i just
i don't thought like shawsh wasn't available then
charge x wasn't available i didn't want a number
on it i didn't want to write like each shash or
crypto i find that a little weird so i just wrote
like xxx like just like that and yeah i didn't
know i will have a following personally as well
so yeah i didn't bother so much it's nothing
to do with porn frankie so guys go follow shash
on twitter um follow altcoinbuzz and check
out their youtube channel um they cover all um
really really exciting projects projects that
i should have gotten into but i didn't because
i'm silly um but now i'm getting into them so
i'm just basically listening to what shash says
and then doing my own research because one should
always do that and then um and then investing
basically um so shash is so good to have you on
do you have any final words do you have any last
i know you've been speaking for nearly an hour
but go on any any last words you'd like to say
yeah i think the one thing i would like to say is
not like the most fun thing that needs to be said
is that one thing is for sure is that bear market
is for buying and bull market is for selling right
so if you've taken profits you're making money
start taking out your profits if you've done 2x 3x
5x start taking your returns back now is not the
time to invest more than you can afford to lose
that time was last year when everybody was crying
uh now is the time to really really not go crazy
things are extremely euphoric market has gone
completely nuts right now and i'm not a financial
advisor but as a friend i can tell you guys that
they look at it long term there will be hundreds
of opportunities that will come towards you people
will be crippling about crypto and saying it's
garbage in two years from now again it's bound to
happen that's the opportunity for you to get in so
think long term you buy too much now and then you
lose money on it is like the last thing you really
want to do so be careful out there have fun learn
as much as you can and the stuff that you buy even
if they correct keep on holding because that's
how much you should believe in it so that's like
me trying to be wise there you know just trying
to be little mature which isn't my style though
no i think it's great all right people always
forget you know bear markets really are for
buying people always get afraid during crashes
and things like that but i for one am certainly
going to go all in and once the bear market is
confirmed that's the that's the risk that's the
level of risk i'm ready i'm willing and ready
to take um i can't do it now because like you
said it's too euphoric and everything's at the
top so i won't take that kind of risk um but
shash i want to thank you so much it's been so
great to have you on um your knowledge is just
like invaluable honestly no it's pretty is that
the word invaluable maybe is that interesting
it's value less
but no value less is like saying that it has no
value like it's zero right yeah so invaluable is
correct right yeah but but last thing also i'd
really like to tell this to everyone as well
which i always tell find something to do in crypto
really this space is not going anywhere this space
is gonna go really really high there is so much
to do so much money to be made get busy right leah
started her channel you guys should start you
know youtube channels or start writing content
start talking about what you like getting your
friends involved start working for an organization
that you like there is a need for thousands
and thousands and hundreds of thousands of
people in the crypto space literally there are
so many opportunities besides just investing
so get on get busy and there's and have fun
yeah there you go guys thank you so much for
watching pleasure to have you and we'll see
you all again next week have a great weekend